- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians, hey Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi David.
- [Voiceover] So today, we're
gonna talk about parentheses.
So, before we get into
what parentheses do,
I would like to talk very
briefly about the word origin
of parentheses or parenthesis,
- [Voiceover] Okay.
because it comes from Greek,
so para means besides,
and thesis means placing, right?
So it's placed beside, approximately,
and how we use parentheses is
we kinda put 'em to the side for little,
what are called asides in
writing, little interruptions.
So let's lay out the
functions of parentheses.
And I should say, the singular form
of parentheses is parenthesis.
That's just one of these.
Two of 'em is parentheses, like so.
So Paige, what is a parenthesis,
and what does it do?
- [Voiceover] So a parenthesis
is a piece of punctuation
that has kind of a lot
of different functions.
It can indicate remarks
by the writer of a text.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Or specify a
definition or a reference.
It can also show
interruptions by an audience,
but overall, the parenthesis separates
a piece of technically
unnecessary information,
or what we called an aside,
from the rest of the sentence.
- [Voiceover] So it separates
inessential information.
- [Voiceover] Right, you can take out
what's in the parentheses,
and the sentence will still make sense.
- [Voiceover] All right, so
let's take these one at a time.
So here we've got something like,
the cookie, which was
still warm, was delicious.
Now we could, conceivably,
take that out of the sentence, right?
'Cause the sentence is basically,
the cookie was delicious.
But if we wanted to
add an additional remark by a writer,
which is whoever ate
the cookie, namely me,
we would put in this parenthetical remark.
- [Voiceover] Right, it's
some extra information.
- [Voiceover] And when
I say parenthetical,
I'm talking about this little aside here.
That's what I mean by a parenthetical.
So this is what's called
a parenthetical aside.
So the second way in
which you use parentheses
is to specify a definition or reference.
So let's say I wanted to quote
Paige's as yet unwritten autobiography.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So, what I'm doing here
is I'm using this parenthetical aside
to cite where in her book she said,
"Oh no, a tiger!"
So let's say this is, what I'm doing here,
this sentence is like an excerpt
from some essay that I'm writing
about Paige's life and times,
which I've italicized
here because it is a book.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So what I'm
doin' here is I have the quote,
and then, in order to say where
that reference comes from,
I give the author's last name,
the name of the book, and then p. 38,
and all of that is inside
parentheses, like so.
That's the second use of the parenthesis.
So let's say you're taking
down a transcript of a speech.
You're typing up someone's speech,
and they start coughing, and it interrupts
the way they're giving a speech.
Let's say I was trying
to render the sentence,
"Furthermore, (coughs) I
must firmly state that."
- [Voiceover] Right, so you
can include the coughing
in the sentence
- [Voiceover] Right.
when you're writing it
down or transcribing it.
Like, if we think this is
important enough to note,
we can just sort of say, voop, voop,
yup, coughing happened here.
- [Voiceover] I see.
So those are the uses of the parenthesis.
You can indicate remarks by the writer,
as in our first example,
or specify a definition or a reference,
which we did here with
the reference to my book,
or you can show an interruption in speech.
That's it!
- [Voiceover] Sweet!
So what happened with that tiger?
- [Voiceover] That's a long story.
- [Voiceover] All right,
we'll talk about that later.
You can learn anything.
Dave out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.